hey guys this is andrew for
trainingsenses.com
i've been working as a professional
trader for the past six years in hong
kong and right now guys i'm doing
youtube videos
because i want to show you guys all the
different tools and techniques that i
use
every day at work that worked for me i
want to show you
how to use it guys and i want to
basically uh
explain to you how portrayers are making
money on the market so if you want to
know about all the stuff
you guys are in the right place so today
i want to make
an update on gamestop again using illiad
wave principle
let's get into it
[Music]
so guys for those who know what is idiot
wave principle
so it's a very complex theory that is
amazing that is working very well
so for those who are completely new to
this what i'm gonna
talk about today is gonna look very
crazy but for those who know a bit it's
gonna
be easier to understand so first thing
idiot wave
principle says that moves up developing
five waves and moves down
corrective moves are developing in three
waves abc
so i'm having here the gamestop price
action
uh let's go on a four hours time frame i
try basically
to apply this theory to this
uh whole move up that we're having since
last march so for the past
year what i'm trying to do here guys is
to see
if actually the waves are completed
the cycles are finished or not and i'm
trying to see if
we are starting a new cycle so for a
cycle to be done you need to find
five waves guys so i spent a lot of time
doing the stuff and look what i found
so once again for those who want to
understand more about iliad just click
on the link in the description of the
video
and you guys gonna receive a free video
where i explain everything when i
show you guys the different patterns
that you have and i showed you some
practical cases
like this one here i don't have time to
uh to go too much into details
so i'm just gonna show you that i have
one here all right so this is the blue
let's put it in red so i have a one here
two
three four and five so my first
cycle of five waves has to me been
completed
when we went to 480 why i think this
counting is correct because each time
the first wave the third wave and the
fifth wave
i can break them down into five waves
and the second and the fourth wave
which are corrective can be broken into
five waves here for triangle of
three waves here for a zigzag so
i am quite confident in this counting
so this is telling me guys that right
now
we have something very interesting that
is starting
because here we have definitely a zigzag
abc
you know but on a bigger cycle and
we are just starting a new cycle gaze so
we are starting a new cycle
that is that started at 50 and look guys
in youtube theory
you know it's just like pattern
recognition
but what is interesting is that you
always have some news
that are going into the direction of the
theory
and here guys what was the news the news
at this levels
was that robin hood increased the margin
so that people can buy unlimitedly
they can you know buy as much as they
want they just need to put more money on
their account
but you guys know that we are full of
cash right now because of the heavy
money printing done by the federal
reserve so i don't worry about people
having cash on their account
they do because they receive free money
even if they don't work
so they have the cash they're going to
put it in gamestop and imc guess this is
what is actually happening and this is
showing me guys that
actually something here happened so that
we don't correct
deeper and we just started guys a new
cycle
that is going to be again developing in
five waves
so here is the 50 level it's actually
the breakout level that we had
let me show this quickly if i go on a
weekly time frame
and i just connect the two recent highs
that i had here and here
tool 13 and 207 guys so technical
analysis
works in a very long term i have this 50
level that has
been broken re-tested here exactly when
we had this correction
and now we are going higher and i expect
this new cycle to develop again in five
waves
so i'm coming to my conclusion very soon
but guys this is
very bullish so we have a one we went to
200
then we have the correction and then we
start again a new third wave
so let me get rid of this first so here
we have
one the two and now i try to guess what
is happening but guys i believe that
we're going to have five waves
and if we do the third wave must be
broken down
in five waves too so the third wave
must have one two three four
and five the third wave is not even
complete guys
so we are in the third wave right now we
know that we have
support level at 175
i showed you guys this in the video i
did uh yesterday or two days ago
on the short term so 175 is gonna act as
support i believe and we're gonna have a
fifth wave that is only gonna be guys
probably go to 480 and then
we're gonna have a correction this is
gonna be the fourth wave here we have a
zigzag
so here probably we're gonna have a flat
uh once again guys flat and zigzags
uh in uh second and fourth wave
corrections
are usually uh switching if you have
first to zigzag then you usually have a
flat
and once again if you wanna know what
i'm talking about guys click on the link
in the description and
you're gonna understand everything here
i expect we have a correction
so here it was a zigzag so here's
something maybe smoother
and then the fifth wave guys and the
fifth wave
is gonna be then the last wave of this
new market
cycle so we are just in the middle of
this market cycle
and now if you want to have some targets
so once again i just gave you some i
think the third wave is going to
you know this is my preferred scenario
of course there is nothing guaranteed
so the third wave in orange that is
itself
that where you can find five waves
inside uh it
is to me going to 480 this would make
sense as is a strong
resistance then we're going to correct
and then we're gonna have the fifth wave
that is gonna break
everything here and to know where the
fifth wave is actually gonna go
guys there are different tools that you
can use for example fibonacci extensions
and i'm gonna show you how to do it in
another video
so if you enjoyed this this one please
don't forget to click on the like sub
and bell button so you're gonna be the
first to know when i
upload anything new and stay close to
show i'll see you guys